so they decided to call it quits
seems like it's a long ways away
six four and three let me see that
well at least i didn't come in last
place otherwise i would have flipped the
board
you want to flip the board brad
no
don't flip the board with the board i
flipped it
i don't think i'm skilled enough
dexterous fingers broken into multiple
all these different pieces
and then the
development so do you think that we
should stage a revolution or is the cost
too high
um i think if we all like 3d print our
own guns
and then just uh
stockpile ammunition
what about a bloodless revolution like
the one that toppled the ussr
bloodless i don't know you need
how good are you well in the age of the
internet i guess wouldn't be that hard
because you could destabilize a country
politically without uh having to leave
your couch you're gonna have to hand out
like pamphlets because uh
you know anything yeah i saw an article
recently about there's certain guns
you're allowed to 3d print
well no it's in certain states there's
no law against 3d printing your own guns
i just watched the if i see the video on
this like four months ago i just watched
it last night but uh
i just saw it i didn't read the whole
article i don't know if texas was one of
those but i've always like i was a
machinist and like the reason i got into
machining is because i always wanted to
be able to make my own gun but
wait i i did not just say that on a live
stream
no i wanted to work for six hour and i
was like i'm not moving in new hampshire
[ __ ] new hampshire i think it's okay to
say that you wanted to make your own gun
why not
yeah i was going to be able to and then
i'm like oh [ __ ] i don't want to move to
[ __ ]
whatever the [ __ ] new hampshire is
new hampshire yeah it sounds made up
connecticut
it's one of those like tiny states that
like they just smushed together
yeah it's up there in the northeast with
like
vermont
and [ __ ] maine and [ __ ]
massachusetts
those
those mass holes dude
those crass mess halls
um will you give me that longest road
please ball
someone's taking a morning dab it's five
you're taking a morning dab
yeah
i wish i
could do that
eight
animal vacation
all these fit in here
yeah
i'll do it
okay
that's
kind of like expert spatial awareness
the type that helps you like win
something yeah they call me kyle fitton
house
in the in the slides
in the house
[Music]
they call me kyle mitten mouse
because
i have the tiniest mittens
i'm from the mitten
will you help me kyle's fit and blouse
because that's my king that bag behind
you
i don't know what goes in it but
the hans might oh i think the
i don't know
well i mean you guys got all those
pieces out still
oh look at the the robber the burglar
the uh
where the [ __ ]
so
um
i
was gonna say something
there we go
so would you ever get a vasectomy
i don't think i would i kind of wanted
like kids somewhere you know in this
world
well i mean yeah but you have to pay
money to get it reversed i don't know if
i'd ever been in a position to where i
could afford that but what if you want
you could bust in chicks all the time
i'd do that anyway
what yeah
you shouldn't do that not all the time
it just as long as they lie to me and
tell me they're on birth control i'm
like
tired i don't even
ask i'm just like
i did all i could do what how much more
can i i couldn't have been unexpected
yeah i mean pretty good or a hundred
percent
because there's not a lot of wiggle room
i got a girl pregnant no no
it was like a random one-night thing and
uh she hit me up like
later i don't know how long she was like
later so under nine months yeah
and then uh yeah we took care of it did
you ever think maybe she was just
getting you to pay for somebody else's
abortion i did think that yeah but uh
someone else's you can have everyone you
know whatever
you know what i thought whatever i'll
help a girl kill a baby doing my duty
i just figured you know
she offered to pay for half so i was
like all right cool did you go with her
to the abortion this one night santa
girls no i didn't i know i know i i
thought about everything but you know at
the same time i'd rather do that than 18
years like you didn't listen to the
heartbeat dude what proof do you even
have this yeah she showed me paperwork
she showed me the paperwork she
could have fabricated it but i was
talking to my cousin about this and he
was like
it's better than just 18 years of
like child support or something i guess
we never thought you'd like want to
raise a kid and like uh you're like oh i
never thought i'd be the guy to raise a
kid but
this girl was like
her name was like one night stand
material yeah she she might as well like
she was super hippy like
like her name was like
willow like tree
hey no you never thought you'd look at
this little baby with dreadlocks and be
like hey
i'll give this a shot
i want kids i want a few kids one day
oh you missed your chance
yeah hopefully that was not the last
chance but
where do these go huns
what
oh wait there's a piece
what is this
it's about
there's boats
[Laughter]
like a monkey that discovered
the
fire cola can
dude imagine a monkey drinking coca-cola
for the first time to be like
this isn't water
or like whiskey for the first time
you think that i've seen some when i was
in thailand i saw some uh these baboons
they would steal your beer it was like a
like you paid to go see them
you paid to go see baboons yeah it was
like you rode forward you wrote an
elephant you
there was a baboon show they were like
slam dunkin basketballs into this like
basketball hoop over this like water
tank it was crazy there was a snake show
you also got to sit in like this foot
bath with fish that like ate the dead
skin off here i was in the military man
it was well that makes sense but if i
was in thailand and someone was like hey
you want to go see baboons and
i was like yeah and they're like hey you
have to pay and i'd be like
we paid like now let's go [ __ ] some kids
dollars for all this [ __ ] it was like
it was so cheap in thailand thailand's
crazy dude thailand is nice yeah so i've
heard
it's it's pretty cool
i uh
i still don't know how you fit all this
in there there's two boxes huh that's
one that's what i told her
yeah that's a that was a pretty easy one
yeah
so now you put a list over there there's
two boxes
two boxes huh
is that her sister
what no you never you never met a girl
with it with two vaginas
no we call that the butthole
that's the other hole
staring well there are people that have
multiple giants yeah you never mind
they're both functioning though you ever
heard of octopussy
eight [ __ ]
no it's a movie yeah octopussy james
bond right why don't you just say that
you [ __ ] weird [ __ ] well you guys
are talking about two [ __ ] and then
you're trying to switch it up like i'm
the weird one i don't know what you're
talking about right now dude you need to
you need to go to therapy
will you drive me
i don't have a car i have a car can can
i get a ride home off here where are you
going riverside
yeah i'll give you a ride home thanks
where are you going
georgetown he's going uh north
yeah i'll give you a ride home where are
you going south austin
nice congress uh south lamar
i live by like uh the wheat spill and in
and out and
pine house and all that
so um
somewhere over the rising sun that's two
songs do you know that i hope you do the
rising sun is the japanese
see the flag for the world war ii yeah i
missed that that was a cool ass flag but
i wish they hadn't like done all that
[ __ ] in china you can't even fly anymore
without looking like an [ __ ]
yeah because they raped a bunch of
people yeah you ever hear of nan king
you guys know about that
they had a you ever rape a whole city
a genghis khan
do you ever rape a whole planet
brick
yeah from rick and morty you have
me yeah your people huh
that's not true man
no man alabama doesn't travel they stick
right where they're at
they don't truly stick it keep it inside
broadly towards just
you know your your people
oh you're kind of colonizers
whatever you guys
insinuated sometimes sometimes you gotta
[ __ ] just rape a planet you know
you know whatever hey i mean everyone is
trying to do it next time out there
first yeah
mercury
yeah our dicks are gonna melt off
because there's no atmosphere but
we're gonna have a good time until then
good game today guys yeah
call it a stream for breaking my
container
i love you all please be happy
brad please